welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host pablo esco spoils and in this
video we're breaking down the ending of
narcos mexico the final season is now
out on netflix and it brings to a close
the entire rock that was set up by the
death of kiki all the way back in the
first entry throughout this video we'll
be talking about the events in the
finale whether amado is still alive and
how things played out in real life full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then i highly
recommend that you check out now if you
enjoy the video then please click the
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
for breakdowns like this each and every
day without the way thanks for clicking
this now let's get into narcos mexico
season 3.
okay so season three is primarily
focused around amado who we learn has
very much filled the void left behind by
felix after his arrest in the first
episode we discovered that in prison he
had somewhat of an epiphany amada
realized that and everyone being
connected that there was a risk that
could all be brought down together
fueled by the death of his daughter he
realized that bad luck will eventually
come to everyone and the only way to
avoid it is to cut off the chances of it
getting to you romano lens had a
character called hank has started to
expand into juarez and thus he kills his
business partner in order to strike up a
deal with him hank is nicknamed the
kingmaker and his political influence is
so strong that it's said he can even
decide who the next president of mexico
should be hank has the power to also
make it so that if people across the
border get caught then it can't be tied
back to the cartels and this new
infrastructure seems like the best way
to handle everything armed with his
daughter's airplane model the lord of
the sky sets out to create an alliance
that will somewhat compartmentalize the
cartels so that they can all keep their
territories without worrying that
they'll lose out should things go south
being narcos though not everyone plays
nice army watches the tijuana and
sinaloa cartels end up going
head-to-head in a gang war that involves
several attempts on the other members
lives felix's warning at the end of
season 2 very much comes to pass and the
criminal dealings escalate to heights
that spill over into the public leading
to the death of a high-ranking cardinal
during a shoot-out between the two sites
this then leads to the arrest of el
chapo and whilst the war between the
cartels does take a lot of the focus in
the season there are also several really
interesting side stories involving lots
of characters that shed light on the
entire situation firstly we have walt
who decides to return to the dea task
force in order to attempt to bring down
the cartels he very much puts his job
over his personal life and this is
somewhat reflected in andrea a
journalist for a paper that wants to
expose the cartels and everyone
connected to them mixed in with this is
victor who for me had the most
interesting story in the entire season
he's very much a crooked cop who ends up
becoming somewhat of a good guy after he
learns of a serial killer operating in
his hometown
i was absolutely gripped seeing him
become a man hunter that put tracking
down the murderer over his own interests
and this eventually led to his death
which we'll talk about later on in this
video narcos mexico very much deals in
shades of grey and as always it's
interesting to see how people's morality
changes depending on the situation the
major event that sparked the entire
thing off was very much the death of
kiki who was tortured before he was
murdered however we watch as walt also
enables his own allies to carry out
torture themselves in order to get
information and thus it becomes clear
that the entire war has corrupted almost
everyone now world very much wrestles
with doing the right thing and after
learning that one of the people they're
interrogating is actually carrying dual
citizenship with america he does
whatever he can to get them out safely
this is alex someone who barely got his
feet wet and then found himself wanted
by both the authorities and the cartels
in the season we very much learned that
walt's brother died and he sees saving
him as somewhat of a chance at
redemption however alex ends up escaping
and this leads to his death a bigger
conspiracy is unearthed along with this
due to andre's investigation and she not
only learns things about hank but also
general robayo who was working alongside
walt and the dea the us and mexican
government had given him completely
unrivalled access to all their inner
workings but we discovered that he was
entirely corrupt and actually on the
payroll of the cartels the kick starts
the finale with a bang and amano ends up
giving his entire empire over to his
brother vincent this is so that he can
escape to chile with his girlfriend
marta but the exposure of robayo makes
the u.s double down on attempting to
capture him though the editor of andre's
newspaper the voice is shot at the
corruption is left wide open and we
learn that over 40 journalists have been
killed thus far in mexico this hit on
the editor also brings down the
indestructible soldier david baron who
is killed by a ricocheted bullet from
his own men elsewhere victor who has
started working for the cartel seemingly
captures the serial killer he executes
him at the side of the road after
confirming that there are scratch marks
on his chest from women fighting back
and it appears that he's finally brought
justice to the murder victims
unfortunately he ends up following some
of the authorities out into the desert
where he learns that the killings have
continued and that more bodies of women
have turned up that were murdered after
he killed the killer it's a complete gut
punch and victor never learns if he
actually caught the killer or not it's
said that it could likely be the result
of several murderers operating within
the area who are able to get away with
their crimes because the authorities
just don't care sadly throughout the 90s
several bodies started to pile up in the
desert of women who worked in the
factories alongside the border we
learned that this continues to this day
even after a movement was created by
women that demanded answers on exactly
what was going on due to corruption
misogyny and lack of care in juarez
bodies have piled up in their thousands
over the decades and though victor
seemingly got one killer many more
remain at launch now unfortunately
because he exchanged cartel information
with the dea in order to get dna and
license plate information his name is
marked one of the big worries within the
cartels was informants and victor is
killed by his partner after his links to
the authorities are discovered it's very
nihilistic especially because most of
the info that vincent got from the dea
was completely useless and he ended up
tracking down the potential killer
through obsessing over things now as sad
as this all is victor isn't actually a
real life figure and his inclusion in
the series seems like it's put in place
to unearth a lot of things not only does
it draw attention to the femicide being
carried out but it also shows the
difference between amado and the
policeman whilst the former pulls in
millions the ladder scrapes by on just
150 dollars per month and thus it shows
why people end up turning to crime
however victor ends up somewhat
redeeming himself and through this he
shows the morality that the policemen
have in the area now though he doesn't
manage to get out one character that
seems to is a motto though the show
doesn't say for definite if we look at
the clues that are left behind it does
seem like he manages to escape with his
life now before diving into this i have
to make it clear that as far as things
go in real life it is believed that
amado is indeed dead however there are a
lot of mysterious things around his
demise that the show definitely leans
into now firstly in the finale we watch
as he sends murder to chile and he sets
out to attempt to change his appearance
so that he can go underground however
amaro stares at his phone and the show
hints to us that he actually contacted
the authorities who arrive at the
hospital the next day according to the
official story they got an anonymous tip
and arrived there to find that his heart
had given out during his surgery now
what's strange about this is that the
mexican authorities confirmed the body
was his but then it subsequently
disappeared not long after the doctors
who carried out the surgery were killed
and the mid-credits scene seems to hint
to us that the makers of the show
believe he staged the entire thing and
managed to cover his tracks we joined
marta at a house in chile which amado
paid for and she comes home to find two
wine glasses poured for her as well as
the toy plane that amado kept to remind
him of his daughter though he will
likely never know whether he got out or
not the implication is definitely that
he survived and managed to do what so
many others weren't able to which is to
make it out the game alive now this
isn't the case for everyone and one of
the key cartel players ramon is killed
in one of the final scenes after
learning the location of up-and-coming
trafficker myo he heads out to kill him
however he's stopped by sinaloa cartel
members that are posing as the police
and he dies by the side of the road as
for mayo he calls ramon's sister and
adina to tell her that her brother is
dead and it's clear that the war is only
going to get worse with everyone out for
blood in prison el chapo moves out
anyone who could be a threat to his
reign and he takes control of the
location and the cartels within it
alongside maya they plan out the future
and with amano gone they decide to move
things into juarez now though this is
the end of narcos mexico that doesn't
mean that things are over and there are
other directions that they could take
things we could end up getting narcos
juarez colombia and really any location
that carries things on so far season 4
hasn't been announced but el chapo has a
long legacy and he's arguably the most
famous drug trafficker alongside pablo
escobar he had a hold over the market
for decades and actually escaped prison
in 2001 it was revealed that he had
complete control over the entire staff
including the warden who is now in jail
for aiding chapo's escape over the
following two decades he was caught and
arrested several times but he managed to
escape many prosecutions due to his
network connections in 2016 he was
extradited and sent to the us for
prosecution though chappell promised not
to have any of the jiras executed they
were kept anonymous and he was sentenced
to life in prison plus 30 years he also
had to forfeit over 12 billion dollars
of his fortune and he now resides in
america's most secure super max prison i
think his life on the run and the
several manhunts that they used to track
him down would make for a really
gripping show and i'd love to see things
head in that direction if we get another
season as for hank he died in 2001
surrounded by his family and friends 2
000 people attended his funeral and
several monuments still stand in mexico
that commemorate him in 1998 the us
authorities launched operation white
tiger which would unearth his money
laundering and ties to organized crime
but this was quickly shut down by him
and his allies janet reno even ended up
issuing an apology and though andre is
dismayed by this she continues to
publish the truth finally we catch walt
working undercover once more and he's
pretty much boring his heart out to the
target he explains there's no way to
actually fix the situation in mexico and
for every cartel member they get rid of
more pop up though it's quite a
depressing ending to see that walt's
work was pretty much worth nothing it is
possible that he ended up repairing his
relationship in the background we can
catch snow and christmas songs being
played and it is possible that this is
actually chicago due to the midwest sign
that hangs there i really hope that he
returned to dany and repaired things and
i think these little clues are put in
place to hint towards that world is also
entirely fictional but with this guy
being make-believe why can't we just
wish him the best and say let's make
believe that he got back with danny
anyway that ends the series and though
this was a slow burn i absolutely loved
it narcos it's a prestige television
show that i think netflix don't promote
enough and it's difficult to really
fault the season as it knocks out the
park on every level and brings things to
a fitting close if you don't already
like narcos then this won't be for you
but if you enjoy the show i think you're
gonna absolutely love it it perhaps
doesn't have some of the iconic
performances like escobar and felix but
it's still very gripping and engaging
and just the perfect closing chapter i
think because it's missing out on some
of the big names and spectacles that it
does get bumped down from being a 10 out
of 10 but hey like i said i can't really
draw many criticisms over it i
absolutely love the season and because
of that it gets a 9.5
i would love to see it back and
obviously let me know below what you
thought of the show as a thank you
you'll be entered into a competition on
the 30th of november in which we're
giving away three copies of the zack
snyder dc trilogy on blu-ray all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the show we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
emails to watch then make sure you check
out our ending explained breakdown of
the eternals which will be linked on
screen right now we went over the full
plot of the movie and talked about those
post-credits scenes so it's definitely
worth heading over there right after
this if not then thanks for sitting
through this video i hope to see you on
the next one and if you don't there's
gonna be problems um i promise you that
either way enjoy the rest of your week
don't worry about that threat too much
and hopefully i'll see you soon you take
care peace